all right we're now live for the March
uh 2023 I'm still getting in the habit
of saying 2023 AMA
um got some questions lined up already
that will take me a couple minutes and
you can write your other questions those
of you who are already participating I
see there's there's uh 12 people already
lined up
so the first one is about uh Kant
from laps nine Continuum why was
contradiction or lack thereof so
important to morality as Kant understood
it it seems the element of contradiction
is what makes the categorical imperative
so powerful and binding what is the
incoherence of ideas have to do with
wrongness so we start with something
pretty substantive there
um first of all I'll say that that lack
of contradiction or contradiction being
a sign that something is wrong is
definitely not unique to conscient
ethics
um
you see it in Epictetus with stoic
ethics right
um he talks about uh mahe or
contradiction and that's that's kind of
an important matter uh you want to try
to like avoid those you could think
about Thomas Hobbs in his discussions of
the absurdity of people acting contrary
to the laws of nature there's
discussions running throughout right so
contradiction is definitely not unique
to Kant or to the categorical imperative
and I think it's important to remember
too that the categorical imperative has
three formulations
a contradiction or lack thereof is
important to the first formulation
uh it's not important in any explicit
way as far as I can tell to the second
you know which is act always so as to
treat Humanity in your own person and
that of others always as an end never as
an or means and then the third
formulation about the kingdom of ends I
don't think it's a
actually quite as as Central in there
but so let's talk about the first
formulation of the categorical
imperative
um why would contradiction you know in
the maxim that you're proposing that as
a universal law why would contradiction
be important well because it shows you
that some things are going to be
incoherent and if they're incoherent
then it's not what a rational being
ought to be doing or justifying or
claiming for itself and I think it's
it's that straightforward I don't think
there's any great mystery here it's not
just looking for contradiction that's
the issue you also have to formulate
your Maxim and then universalize it you
know sort of imagine what the world
would be like what the entailments of it
would be so contradiction is one of
several different moving parts that are
involved in the first formulation of the
categorical imperative
all right so
um let's move on to jupes this one's
easy to answer
have you ever had an interest in the
philosophy of science not much if so
what works in that area did you read and
what did you think was the most valuable
I mean I've read philosophy of science
insofar as I've had to
um you know we had preliminary
examinations that had reading lists for
epistemology and philosophy of science
as one of the four uh prelims and you
know so I read the standard Fair staff
who in the structure of scientific
evolutions and you know other various
things along the way some you know uh
lockatos and some popper and people like
that
um and so you know that's that's
basically been it I you know I I'm I'm
not competent listed as an area of my
competency because I don't read that
stuff very much
um and you know I kind of think that
there's
you can you can pick at most like five
or six areas that you're going to work
in productively and competently and
going beyond that is is kind of kind of
tough all right
um
quintessential you're not late where
you're just getting started here Eamon
would you compare contrast starts nausea
Nietzsche great pity and great nausea
and Humes pity as a form of hate
obviously very different
um
yeah I mean I'd have to go back to Hume
uh treaties part book two to see pedia
is a kind of hate doesn't sound right to
me
um but I'd have to take a look at it
because usually pity is is construed
classically as being a form of feeling
bad that other people are are feeling
bad or doing bad
um but
starts nausea
um
is not the same thing as Nietzsche's
discuss or mentions of nausea here and
there you know SARS is more like a
reaction to the the whole world I mean
you know the first place that Nietzsche
references nausea by the way is birth a
tragedy
I want to say in part three of it but
it's been a while since I've been in
there and I remember being struck by
that
back when I you know
a decade ago when I was like reprising
these works and being like holy crap
maybe that's maybe that's where that
came from but I I don't think there's a
huge connection between those hey Mark
good to see you there speaking of so you
said speaking of Kant just ramping up
the third critique your thoughts on the
text specifically his idea that human
teleology is to be found in our culture
not sure what the German term is yeah I
I think that uh you know so this is
going to be a little bit of a rant
a lot of times people will be like you
know especially when they're like
looking at my top 10 books in in you
know philosophy type books I'd bring to
a desert island sort of thing they're
like why not Khan's first critique and
I'm like because I wouldn't bring cats
first critique you know if I was going
to bring any Kant uh one single book it
would either be the second critique or
the third critique or it would be the
full metaphysics of morals which
includes the metaphysical elements of
virtue and the metaphysical elements of
Justice because that stuff's way more
interesting I I don't find the first
critique you know to be I've talked
about this in the text with aura thing
people take it as oh such an important
work of philosophy and it's important
but it's not like Earth shattering I
think there's a lot of people sort of
buying the uh self-serving propaganda
about the copernican turn you know I
mean it's interesting it's it's
important but it's not that important
the third critique I think is where a
lot of cool stuff happens and as a whole
I don't think the book has the same sort
of let's call it
um everything hanging together and you
can see exactly how you're getting from
one place to another is the first two
critiques go but there's a lot of really
really cool stuff in there right
discussion of what do we consider to be
beautiful and why do we disagree about
matters of Art and Beauty the discussion
of the sublime is really cool all this
teleological stuff is really really cool
as well
so I I you know I'm kind of a fan of the
third critique I think you can tell I'm
like warming up right
um red stoica asked the question that
everybody somebody asks every single
time and I always give the same answer
uh can you do episodes on Eastern
philosophies first of all there's no
such thing as Eastern philosophy that
itself is the wrong way to look at it
there's Chinese philosophy and the
entire Chinese Cultural sphere which
extends into you know Japan and Korea
and stuff like that but each of them
brings their own thing to it and that's
very different than Indian in the Indian
subcontinent and its philosophies and
stuff like that and we've got you know
all the stuff that's happening along the
Silk Road with very interesting
interactions we've got Islamic
philosophy so let's avoid that term
Eastern philosophy because that's
already kind of orientalism
um and why don't I do stuff on that uh
because I don't read The Source texts in
in the original languages if I want to
read Cicero I can read Latin if I want
to read
um stuff in you know Chinese or Japanese
or Indian philosophy I don't read
Japanese or classical Chinese or you
know for that matter my Mandarin never
got better than reading 250 characters I
don't read Sanskrit I don't read Paulie
so
I'm leery of wandering in and doing
stuff on stuff that I can't like go back
to the source text and I'm not a
specialist in any of those you know I've
taught that stuff but that doesn't mean
that I'm the person to be doing videos
on it and the third thing is we have a
division of labor in the philosophical
world not everybody has to do everything
there's plenty of great people out there
doing work on you know stuff from the
Indian or Chinese Cultural sphere and so
you should go to them and look at their
stuff rather than asking somebody who
doesn't do that kind of stuff to you
know shift their emphasis and focus on
that I don't even get to uh most of the
authors that I I would like to cover in
European philosophy you know or
classical American philosophy let alone
these other things that other people are
much better at doing
oh Bruno nice to see you here thanks for
another of those self-directed studies
videos those are really cool yeah I
think they they serve a kind of purpose
I mean it would be cool if other people
were making them as well so we could get
some different takes on uh some of these
figures you know maybe there's there's
things I'm leaving out
um I will be doing one later this month
uh with a video premiere on Hegel and
then we're probably going to go back it
looks like the you know people were more
interested in Augustine and then him and
then we'll do Hobbs and then we'll see
where we go from from there you know and
there's plenty of other people that will
do down the line if I crank them out one
a month then we can actually get quite a
bit done
all right uh let's see it just skipped a
little bit
um
Jacob Murphy much in the market for a
complete works of Plato which do you
recommend uh looking at jowitz 1937
random house or the edited by John
Cooper and whatever one is you want to
do is fine I mean I don't care which one
you read
um you know
there
they're both fine uh Cooper is a more
recent translation
um you know there's uh jaw it didn't
translate all the stuff uh himself right
so
um I think it's it's useful sometimes to
look at multiple translations if you
can't go back to the original so I don't
I don't endorse one over the other or
anything like that
um
on milahan philosopher's corner do you
favorite Game of Thrones
character now that is a good one I
certainly have some favorite
you know obviously Jon Snow
and Tyrion Lannister and Arya right and
um you know in the books at least
Daenerys I don't think she was done
particularly well in the
um
uh the Game of Thrones series we're
talking about the Song of Ice and Fire
um
who else
I mean you know you feel kinda
something for Samuel tarly
um Brienne of course and actually I do
like the Hound you know even though he's
kind of a bastard
um you can definitely feel some empathy
for him now if I had to pick my favorite
one uh you know also in the books Jamie
Lannister is not quite
the bastard
and sister screwer that he is in the
show right and he does have like kind of
like a Redemption Arc
um
probably were dictarian you know
um but it's it's kind of tough there's
there's some really well developed uh
characters in that that whole mix so
all right uh Leslie married gay Catholic
priest and Blondell scholar John McNeil
used blondell's work to advocate for
acceptance of queer sexualities in the
church what are your thoughts on his
work uh do you believe same-sex unions
are based on disordered affection that
cannot endure blah blah blah
um so I I actually corresponded with
O'Neill at several points uh back in the
day when I was still in graduate school
and early on and he tried to sort of
enlist me in some public campaign that
he was attempting to do at one point
that fizzled out
um and so I think that O'Neill you know
O'Neil was a an activist who had
definitely been kicked around a lot by
the church of his time silenced for a
while you know treated pretty poorly I
don't think as a blown Dell scholar that
he was particularly great and so there's
that side and then there's the you know
um sort of like constantly pushing the
envelope on sexuality
you know I've thought about this a lot
over my time and I I think that
um it's not something intrinsically
disordered or if it is then we ought to
look at it as intrinsically disordered
as everything that heterosexuals are
engaging in themselves you know you look
at the the divorce rates and
um you know the constant you know string
around and obsession with uh everybody
else's sexuality and the proliferation
of pornography and abusive relationships
and I don't I don't think that gay
relationships are any more subject to
that than heterosexual relationships and
that's my view on it so
you know I think what we're going to see
is a reevaluation of this sort of stuff
going on and I think there's grounds for
it already
um that said I I didn't you know I
didn't find
um uh O'Neill who I mean
or McNeil who's who's who's like brought
him up right recently he's he's been
gone for quite a while
um
I didn't find his stuff all that
compelling so
all right uh mistful what do you think
about slavo zizak I think there's
interesting stuff there you got to Wade
through a lot of crap to get to the
interesting stuff and that he like many
continental people is much more prone to
like throwing out a whole bunch of stuff
in front of you without enough
um drawing the careful drawing the lines
between things so I think ggx early work
is rigorous and good I think that much
like Dairy da as time went on and he
became a star I think the the quality of
it declined considerably
um so
all right uh Felix
may you give me your two cents on
ethnocentrism or King Kim Claire's book
about the black Korean conflict I I
haven't read it so I don't even know who
Kim Claire is
um ethnocentrism uh very common leads us
into all sorts of stupid things
um all sorts of problems so but it is a
kind of common cultural tendency one
that we're going to probably have to
learn to overcome if we want to ever
have a have our act together as a whole
species you know
um Javier says why do you think so many
psychologists in the U.S so quickly
dismiss psychoanalysis and the whole
field of psychoanalysis well that's
that's an interesting question and it
has to do with a lot of back history for
a long time psychoanalysts basically ran
the show and like a lot of people who
were in power many of them were
dismissive of other approaches even
those brought forward by other
psychoanalysts so you could think about
Albert Ellis and rational emotive
behavior therapy Ellis was originally a
psychoanalyst and he brought forward
this new approach and they excoriated
him for it you could think about you
know Victor Frankel and Logo therapy
right you could think about all sorts of
other things that the psychoanalytic
establishment was constantly pushing
down and repressing and saying that
doesn't fit into these theories right
even you know certain psychoanalysts who
were admittedly kind of kind of uh
off the beaten path like you know Reich
um weren't looked at very well by other
psychoanalysts and that you know the
psychoanalyst dominated the scene for a
long time and then there was this
backlash against that and now what we
see is psychoanalysis a lot of times
just kind of dismissed unfairly because
you know depth therapy or depth
psychology and the therapy is associated
with it they're useful tools you know
um
so I think that's you know explains the
U.S thing
um as a side note you know when you're
reading like huh it's very important to
keep in mind that he was rebelling
against the psychoanalytic establishment
in favor of a return to Freud uh who he
thought that they had essentially
abandoned you know
uh andaliva I was wondering what are
your thoughts on Axel hanith I don't
have any thoughts on Axel hanath
um I've never I've never read
honest work you know I know of hanath as
like part of the kind of penumbra of
critical theory but it's been quite a
while since I was you know doing
Frankfurt School related stuff so I
never got into tahanath
um
milahan philosopher's corner and
Orthodox Christian Theologian who isn't
a heretical work work person is who you
should ask advice from concerning
marriage in Christianity you know
anytime I see the word woke used in that
way I think that the person who's using
it is either a grifter or ideologically
Bound in with their binders or not very
bright so I would avoid trying to talk
about you know woke stuff at least here
because uh you're making yourself look
foolish to the person you're you're
addressing
uh made of clay any good movies or shows
you've seen lately Dr Sadler yeah you
know I've been um
my wife and I have been watching our way
through the second season of Hope Street
which is a BBC Northern Ireland
production uh we've been enjoying that
we just watched the last episode
yesterday we also watched our way
through the new season of Vera which is
about a these are both cop shows uh Vera
is about a Northumberland
um
she's not a chief she's uh
uh I'm forgetting her rank she runs the
show for for you know a police uh uh
homicide group
um I've been watching The Mighty Bush
which is one of my you know people
talked about Comfort shows a while back
there what are your comfort shows what
are the shows that you'll watch again
even though you've seen them because you
just enjoy watching them and for me the
Mighty Bouche uh Red Dwarf which I
watched my way through recently Venture
Brothers those are all shows like that
for for me that I'll you know even
though I've seen them multiple times
I'll go back and watch them haven't seen
any movies lately
um and and that's partly a function of
like being
kind of too busy to to take an hour and
a half or two hours and just sit there
and watch a movie so
all right Luca's got a great question
here
um how does one avoid becoming a
pessimist with regard to the state of
philosophy I know that the end of
philosophy has been announced for a long
time but I still find heart I find it
hard to rid myself of this so let's
there's two different important
questions there let's take the easier
one first
so the end of philosophy people who talk
about that are just full of
because you know if you're a historian
of ideas you know that this like the end
of this has been announced so many times
the end of metaphysics the end of
philosophy you know wickenstein let the
fly out of the fly bottle you know uh
Jean-Luc Mario actually has an article
and this is from like 20 30 years ago
called the end of the end of philos or
the end of the end of metaphysics right
um so people have been talking about
this sort of stuff and essentially
talking out of their ass or doing so in
self-serving projects you know because
with the end of philosophy we're
supposed to like pay attention to their
philosophy people have been doing this
now like the entire 20th century
um so don't worry about that sort of
stuff
um that that's just people you know
being people and and that provides us
with a good leading uh thread into the
other thing how do you avoid becoming a
pessimist with regard to the state of
philosophy uh again you know some
historical perspective is is very useful
you see that you know great philosophers
often get passed over for good stuff or
not read in their own time and or you
know their reputation is ruined think
about Mary woolstone craft after the
Vindication of the rights of women
because her stupid husband after she
dies quite young writes this tell-all
biography that sort of stuff happens all
the time you know there's no direct
correlation between Merit or quality and
you know being paid attention to at any
given point of of history and you know
you see all these non-entities kind of
rising because of their contacts or they
happen to be trendy that's been going on
for centuries so that's not that big of
a deal you know it doesn't have to uh
make you feel bad or bring you down and
you think about how wonderful it is that
we live in a time where we have access
to just
so much cool stuff I mean you could read
the rest of your life and never run out
of interesting new Authors whose thought
and works you can explore well that's
really awesome you know and then if you
want to like you know try to adapt it to
your own life or talk to other people
about it we exist in a time when that's
that's quite possible so I don't you
know I don't think that it's not as if
there isn't any reason to be pessimistic
right but um
being pessimist is kind of a choice
among a whole bunch of different ways of
interpreting the current field of
philosophy so if you find that you know
the the field as you are experiencing it
uh is really bringing you down maybe you
want to migrate to another part of the
vast domain of philosophy and then you
feel better right so
all right uh milahans have you read and
watched House of the dream I don't know
if I I don't really have time for for
that sort of thing spin-offs
um I'm not that interested in the
targaryens quite frankly in their
backstory
um and I moved on to plenty of other
stuff I got the worlds of speculative
fiction series you know so we're we're
now like looking at uh this month and
next month Kim Stanley Robinson's Mars
Series so you know if George Martin
doesn't want to get his act together and
like finish out Song of Ice and Fire and
wants to fart around with other stuff
more power to him but I'm not I'm not
gonna bother with it probably
uh Max what are some of your thoughts on
Ralph Waldo Emerson as a philosopher I'm
doing an American philosophy course this
semester and I find some of his ideas
pretty interesting that's that's
probably a good way to put it some of
his ideas are interesting I don't think
he's like a first-rate philosopher but
he's you know he's an inch interesting
guy and he's got some stuff to put on
the table to consider he's certainly
important in that you know understanding
that milieu of American
transcendentalism which is which is
really cool you know
um there's a lot more to American
philosophy than just pragmatism and
that's that's one particularly important
movement
so you know
somebody who I've I've read
uh particularly since I went to uh uh
Southern Illinois University right where
classical American philosophy was an
important part of the department
the over Giver have you heard the song
Heritage by the metal band The Kindred
nope
um if if it's you know I listen to
mostly what we call Classic or
traditional metal stuff bands that that
started in the 70s or the 80s and you
know they may be continuing on into the
90s 100 you know the the odds as they
call them and then the 20 teens like for
example the two different bands tank or
you know Judas Priest or whoever but I'm
not listening to a lot of newer stuff so
you know generally the response that
you'll get have you heard this band have
you heard this band is going to be nah I
haven't you know I'm usually spending a
lot of time with the catalogs of much
older bands
um and you know it's got if it's got
lyrics about the history of philosophy
that's great I don't go to metal stuff
uh particularly for lyrics about the
history of philosophy
um if it happens to be in there that
that's not nice but as a philosopher
that's not a big draw for me
um Henry Martin you probably get this
question a lot but I'm curious to hear
your thoughts about the decline of the
humanities and universities seems like
most I talk to say it's not really worth
it anymore
um well that's because you probably
talked to people who aren't you know all
that bright uh and and are not like
doing work in the actual field uh or
Fields rather of humanities and what are
we talking about with Humanities we've
got you know literature
rhetoric uh philosophy religious studies
history and a bunch of other other
Associated Fields as well you could
maybe say art history fits in there
um
again sort of like with the end of
philosophy these big announcements all
the decline of the humanities
um you know there was a recent New York
Times I think it was article about that
these are like a little tiny they
usually they're getting like a little
snapshot of like this school over here
and this school over here they're not
doing some massive survey of things you
know there are philosophy departments
that are closing their philosophy
departments that are changing you know
what that they're teaching or they're
shrinking and then there's philosophy
departments that are
cranking along doing just fine and
hiring more people
um you got to look at like the whole
picture people are majoring in
Humanities and going on to have you know
decent careers and decent lives so I I
would I would say a lot of this decline
of the humanities stuff is you know very
selective uh looking at at things
all right uh I just skipped a little bit
let me scroll back up
um
Mr Phil HD what are your thoughts on
marks and capitalism in general
I mean Marx exists capitalism exists uh
you know Marx provides us with some
analysis of how capitalism Works some of
it is interesting and useful some of it
is probably you know a bit too dated
because capitalism itself as Marx
recognized changes the configuration as
we go on and he died back in the you
know 19th century so that's probably
enough right there because that's you
know such high level stuff you know
uh I don't know what we can what we can
say about that Tish says what do you
think about the maxim priority should be
given to worse yeah I mean it's kind of
a a common thing in in a lot of
different ethics uh I have no problem
with that Dr Beavis I've got no
questions just want to give my thanks
for this interesting discussion oh yeah
that's that's very nice of you you're
welcome and glad you're here
Max working my way through the day anima
I'm scratching my head trying to figure
out his interpretation of Plato's demeus
of the soul and book one any things that
you think I should keep in mind
yeah it's often helpful to keep in mind
that Aristotle uh when he's criticizing
Plato is sometimes criticizing uh what
we've got in the actual texts and
sometimes it appears to be stuff that
was like taught at Plato's Academy and
sometimes they get kind of blurred
together I mean the other thing to keep
in mind the day anima as far as like a
systematic text is a hot mess
it's going all over the place and it
opens up a lot of questions that it
doesn't you know completely answer
um
in a way it's it's it's not an
incomplete work but
in a way it is so I would keep all of
that sort of stuff in mind
um
and you know
you can go back to Plato's Tomatoes
there's some some interesting discussion
about the parts of the Soul Aristotle
doesn't accept Plato's tripartite Soul
he's got a different way of dividing up
the soul
um but in the Tomas it's actually
associated with parts of the body right
you know so like here's where the
rational part is here's where thumos is
and then down in our belly in genitals
is where the epithumia the the uh
appetites reside
um so you know that ties in a little bit
with the mind-body connection and stuff
uh Marco says which philosophers would
you recommend concerning the issue of
dealing with guilt uh overthinking a
situation from the past uh you know
the stoics would be good for them Seneca
actually an Epictetus actually talk
about people that we would he doesn't
use they don't use the word overthinking
but uh or like
thinking about things in unproductive
ways but they they had they talk about
that quite a bit in their Works
um I think you can see that in you know
other virtue ethicists like Plutarch
who's a middle platonist
um some of Cicero's works you know
[Music]
um
and then you know you can go on I mean
think about Augustine and his
confessions and his own self-analysis
and whether you can apply some of the
lessons from that to yourself or his his
discussion of the emotions in city of
God you know so there's quite a few
ancient philosophers whose discussions
of like our thought processes and how
they lead to emotions might be useful
for you
um and then you know maybe some
existentialist thinkers
would be useful as well
um
yeah
all right uh
and Olivia who are your favorite critics
of liberalism I don't really have
favorites of a lot of things and
you know
critics of liberalism
is not something I think about or care
enough about
to have favorites in I mean if you're
talking about like people who are
critical of some aspects of whatever
liberalism is supposed to mean you know
that's by itself in equivocal term
um I mean I like Aleister McIntyre right
um I disagree with him on some things
like his read on the stoics or you know
some of the medieval philosophy stuff
um or whether we should Vote or not I
mean he actually wrote a wrote a piece a
while back uh in the 2004 election
making the case that you couldn't really
vote for either party
um
but you know he's a Critic of liberalism
and he's a he's somebody I like but I
don't he's not my favorite qua
critic of liberalism right
elliotic do you believe in God yeah I do
Google user what philosophers do you
kind of live by oh a good question here
sometimes you get the feeling of you
being an eye which looks in all
directions but C follow none well you've
got the you've definitely got the wrong
take with that
um I definitely don't look in all
directions nobody looks in all
directions
um and I I think you know if you follow
me a little bit more closely you you see
me endorsing and and teaching about and
uh oftentimes applying stuff that comes
from a variety of philosophical
traditions so you know in the ancient
world the platonist the Aristotelian and
the stoic movements
um I draw on them pretty uh frequently
um you know I'm a ciceronian eclectic as
I've talked about many times meaning
that I like Cicero draw upon these and
try to systematize them together there's
Christian thinkers you know who I
engage with and like quite a bit you
know the person I've published the most
on is actually Saint Anselm of
Canterbury
um and I've you know done quite a bit of
work on uh early Christian thinkers
um
as well who are reacting to ancient
philosophy
existentialists are important for me
dialectical philosophers but there's you
know there's others who I like some
aspects of and have written a lot about
like Renee Descartes you know so
[Music]
um
you know I it's better to say not that I
live by them but I live in dialogue with
philosophers who I think have something
to contribute to me uh and to you know
my relationships with with other people
I've learned you know a good bit from
say Rainer Maria rilka or Mary
woolstonecraft about what the
possibilities for genuine love and
personal development in a romantic
relationship could be like you know
um so those are just a few examples
um MZ have you read the book what is the
west by Philip Nemo no I haven't read
that
um
again King how realistic is it to do a
bachelor's degree while working a first
full-time job kind of depends on you
know the rigors of both and what your
own capacities are and you know what
your obligations are do you have a
family that you have to support
um do you have things that you know are
going to hold you back physically or
mentally how bad is your job you know
how good is your job do they do they
offer tuition assistance or things like
that I mean there's so many different
factors uh I don't know how we're going
to easily
give a you know sort of like it's it's
exactly 65 percent difficult uh it
doesn't really work like that
um guy what are some current discussions
problems in epistemology I don't know
you'd want to ask somebody who works in
epistemology and that isn't me Ken hey
Ken good to see you here speaking of old
bands I'd strongly recommend the last
few albums from sax and they're every
bit as good now as they ever were yeah
they have been you know Saxon is a band
I'll say this too that has never
disbanded there have been two different
Saxons for a while as a matter of fact
there still are right there's the Oliver
Dawson Saxon who tried to Bogart the
name and then they got their their butts
handed to them in court and then their
sacks and led by Biff Byford
um which is the as far as I'm concerned
the real Saxon and uh yeah they have
released a lot of great albums like in
from well I I won't even say from
Thunderbolt on because there have been
other good albums battering ram stuff
like that going all the way back through
their their whole
um
you know catalog but recently yeah um
they've they've put out some some great
stuff as a matter of fact I'm blanking
on the name of their their album that
came out I think it was 2011 maybe
uh or maybe it was last year and it
actually had a song about covid on it um
which was quite
heart-wrenching in a way
so yeah Saxon they're they're really
good and I've seen them twice in concert
myself I'm sure Ken has seen them you
know uh Ken is fortunate to live over
there where a lot of these bands are uh
touring
um there's so many like great new wave
of British heavy metal bands that are
still together and still touring but
they don't come across the Atlantic or
if they do it's only to a few places so
all right
um
let's see here ashmare do you think
philosophers need to be more public
facing in eras where people look more to
gurus grifters for answering the big
questions do philosophers have a
responsibility to publicly combat this
so two two different questions there
um Do philosophers need to be more
public facing
uh whether it's in an era of gurus or
any other era yeah public some
philosophers need to be public facing
not every philosopher needs to be public
facing as a matter of fact maybe not
even half
um and I would say philosophers who want
to be public facing or engage in public
philosophy but do a crappy job screw
things up for the rest of us so we don't
want just anybody doing that right but
we you know we do want to promote it and
we don't want to you know for example
um
I know students who have come to me
because I do public philosophy and
they've said you know my my professors
are discouraging me from like having a
YouTube channel or doing you know uh
Outreach to the business Community or
stuff like that they're saying I'm
selling out they're saying I'm I'm
wasting my talents I should be focusing
just on academic you know traditional
academic stuff and I'll say well screw
your professors you do whatever the hell
you want it's your it's your life right
and it's really kind of sad that a lot
of these professors I think out of a
sense of like just not understanding or
maybe Envy or fear they they don't want
other people doing this and we do need
people doing public philosophy now is
there a responsibility to go Toe to Toe
and battle the gurus
I don't think so I mean I'm going to be
writing a piece this month uh titled
take the training wheels off which is
going to be about you know people
reading you know say Jordan Peterson and
being like oh he's uh you know I I can't
get rid of him because he was my way
into this or reading you know the daily
stoic which sometimes quotes things that
are actually mistranslations and and
being like oh well that's where I got my
my entrance into stoicism and I my my
response is going to be that's fine you
can remember them fondly
but recognize their limitations if
you're riding a bike you don't keep the
training wheels on like a little little
child for the whole time you're riding
the bike you use those training wheels
and then get rid of them and ride your
bike do real philosophy do real thinking
about stuff you know
um don't keep yourself held down by
these Guru types you know
foreign
question here what do you think drives
creatives to make art I mean it's all
sorts of things
um and you know I'm kind of lucky I'm
I'm working in a place with lots of
creatives Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Design and the only philosopher there
um you know I teach classes like ethics
for artists and designers or philosophy
of human nature or world religions or
you know a bunch of other stuff as well
and so I get students in my classes who
are creatives
and you know what is it that that drives
them some of the same stuff that drives
all of us needing to make an income you
know needing love relationship support
from other people but they also want to
they you know they engage the world they
engage their media they get into these
grooves where they're working
um and they want to express or tie into
something that is you know valuable that
is greater than themselves you know so I
think that's that's part of it
um
vegan sports bar in schopenhauer's
essays he advises one concealed their
talents and intellect to avoid the Envy
of idiots but what one must Express
themselves and why consider others to
such a degree he didn't seem to
um you know he could be saying this is
what I've learned from experience yeah
he was very in your face about his
talents and people thought he was a
prick as a result you know and part of
it was the way in which he did it even
his own mom you've probably seen that
letter where his mom was like you know
you're a smart guy but you really piss
people off you know why don't you learn
and become a you know person who could
actually get along with other people
shopping hour also this is something
I've been meaning to do right writing
about for a while schopenhauer also
thinks that you have a
not only moral permission but perhaps
even duty to protect yourself
from other people
uh who don't have a right to the
information about you that they're
asking for so that uh it's it's not only
okay to lie to some people but it's the
right thing to do you know so yeah
all right uh uh TS apostolos enjoyed
your Tolkien on fairy stories yeah it's
a great essay right uh there's a lot of
cool stuff in there I'd read it before
but sometimes you don't see everything
that you need to until you have to teach
about it which is what I do in the
videos we'll be coming back to some
other Tolkien stuff down the line I
think
um
yeah uh
tugen cake here what do you think about
the Frankfurt School uh they're
interesting you know
um I I read them quite a lot in graduate
school try to do some writing and I did
publish one piece very early on in my
career about adorno largely drawn from
negative dialectics a piece that's
actually been like put into anthologies
and stuff like that
um
I've never been able to effectively
write on a door no after that because
his thought is just like all over the
map I enjoy reading him but it's it's
difficult right and then I mean who else
in the Frankfurt School you know I've
read Eric from I've read Marcus uh you
know I I've read uh
um horkheimer and I and I do like the
dialectic of Enlightenment you know it's
a much more readable work because
porkheimer brings to the conversation
kind of focused that a turtle maybe
doesn't have
um you know and then there's Harbor Moss
I've I've actually taught Harbor moss in
the past and I I do like some of his
stuff you know
um so I think the Frankfurt School they
can be interesting
um so uh or solely two two two two have
you read into any traditional Islamic
theology particularly ones with
Scholastic Traditions such as the
asharis yeah I've I mean I've read some
stuff like I said earlier uh in in
answer to a question about Eastern
philosophy
um I'm not a specialist right I don't I
don't read Arabic so that's kind of a
handicap
um
and uh we only get so many hours in the
day and I spend mine mostly reading
European philosophers not uh not reading
too many other people unless I have some
reason to
um
hunsia Newman I'm researching the
question is the Mind atabala Raza I'd
like to know your opinion on it
um give me a suggestion for books
academic articles on this topic either
against it or for well I can't do the
second because I I don't I don't read in
this area I I've never really taken the
top of La Raza idea seriously because it
seems like a flawed metaphor to me
um I mean it's clear that people want to
attribute to Aristotle but that
Aristotle doesn't think anything
remotely of the kind uh when you
actually like look at his Works
um you know we we have some capacity
some structures kind of in place and I
think it's it's one of those things
where
the way the problem is set up is is kind
of screwy right either it's like there's
nothing in the mind and everything comes
in from the outside and then maybe some
reflection gets turned on it as well
because even the empiricists like lock
and Hume talk about that or like there's
some structures already there in the you
know the the storehouse or the mine ala
Descartes you know
um the
old empiricism versus rationalism you
know thumbnail sketch kind of stuff
I just it doesn't seem like either of
those are adequate to me
um I think it's more interesting to look
at you know how our ideas work together
with what we could call what the
phenomenologists call intersubjectivity
which is you know largely structured by
language and culture and stuff like that
so I mean I don't think there is any
Pablo Raza that you can actually point
to you know
all right
um lapse says I'm inspired by the
Practical achievements of Science and
The Logical Clarity of mathematics what
would you say is the measure of Truth
and philosophical text can we spell out
the criteria nope uh we can't because
nobody's going to agree on it anyway
people have been trying to do that for
hundreds and hundreds of years look back
on the old attempts at that before
suggesting new attempts I would say and
I don't think that there is a single
like mode of Truth you know I think that
we have a number of different ways of
thinking about truth and they don't all
neatly map onto each other and they sure
as hell are not encompassed by just the
correspondence coherence pragmatic
deflationist uh whatever else we're
gonna add I mean there's all sorts of
other important discussions of Truth
that'll often get overlooked by the
people who are bringing these things up
um
so I I don't that's kind of a
non-starter for me I would say
um oh yeah so so Ken brings up the Saxon
thing that I was talking about that uh
remember the fall and the song about
kovid from the album Carpe Diem
um really good album yeah yeah
and you know when Scott and I begin
doing classic metal class again we have
the intention of um doing album reviews
of recently recent albums by new wave of
British heavy metal bands that are still
churning out really great stuff like
girls school has a recent album Raven of
course is constantly you know working on
new stuff
um
there's uh oh Tigers upon pantang have
been putting out new stuff over the last
couple years uh that's that's really
quite good as well so there's there's
going to be some of that
uh Rush Paul uh your recent Descartes
videos have been great thanks for them
any plans for more you even have fans
all the way over here in Taiwan I don't
think I've done any recent Descartes
videos other than the
um self-directed study video right
so
I did
um videos a while back on Descartes uh
uh just the discourse on metaphysics
this course on method and the uh
meditations on first philosophy or
meditations metaphysique
um
so you might be thinking of those
um I'm glad they've been they've been
helpful for you
um I will be doing more stuff on
Descartes down the line I think that
you know if I was going to do another
text
probably the passions of the Soul
um
and I'm going to be offering a class on
Descartes starting in May going through
the the
meditations uh you know over Zoom so
yeah Michael says I'm becoming a
physician but don't find the work
much more appealing than most other
career paths I'm choosing it since docs
have a good salary hours serving other
but not because I love it is there any
hope I can somehow make this career
something I love after all how does one
make a good career from something they
don't love so that's a really great
question
um
and I think that's quite thoughtful and
I'm glad to hear that
you are pursuing the path even though
it's not something at this time that you
really love because
um you know
there are good points to it and the most
important part of this is the idea of
serving others in a very determinate way
you know there are there are goals to
medicine that should never be lost you
know carrying disease alleviating pain
helping people as they approach death
these are very very important matters
and the medical profession is part of
that and I think that you know
there's probably this can be generalized
to many careers
it doesn't have to be rewarding for you
in the ways that you're looking for
right off the bat sometimes you have to
do something for a while
and then you can see
you know what you didn't see before
um sometimes it's experience sometimes
it's dialogue with other people
sometimes it's seeing other Physicians
cases and them burning out and being
like oh what happened there I let me try
to avoid that sort of thing so I think
the the best thing that you can do for
yourself right now is to take the
pressure off of yourself
to
find it you know
intrinsically appealing and say I'm just
going to kind of go with this and you
know and like if you
go to to
um med school and you're doing your
residency maybe you're doing your
residency right now because you say I'm
becoming a physician
um
you know and you give it five years
after that and it doesn't really work
for you well you can do other stuff
there's nothing that says you have to be
locked into that career path forever
right
um but sometimes you do have to like
give it a while to to see what what
comes to mind so that is that is a great
question
um
all right Mark hefling today's media
environment overloads us with quick
takes of lengthy texts that I fear leads
to many people that presume they're
educated but in reality aren't
yeah sure that's that's true you know
little quotes
um I mean
that's always been a problem a lot of
these these quotes that turn out to be
um
wrong quotes you know like the ones that
I bring up in my videos on Aristotle and
Plato and Marcus Aurelius the fake
quotes
they often come from books that were
published around the turn of the century
kind of self-helpy almanacs they would
have all these little quotes in them
right and
um sometimes they would be attributed to
that that person in there and these were
fake quotes right and sometimes it would
just be that person saying it and then
somehow it got attributed to Plato or
Epictetus or pick whoever else right
so this sort of you know complaint we
could make this of many other earlier
Generations
um
all right uh
Andrew is a selfless Good Deed possible
not only possible happens all the time
uh idamar Drury do you think there's a
fundamental difference between the two
concepts what two concepts
um I'm not sure what the context there
is Google user your thoughts on David
Graber I'd have to look up who that that
is the name seems a bit familiar
um
American anthropologists and Anarchist
activists yeah oh uh
he's the guy who wrote jobs I
I've read that actually I'm going to be
doing a review of it I think that's a
great book I've not read anything else
that the guy has written but
jobs is is actually quite good
philosophical analysis of a very
important concept so yeah
all right uh yeshu seeking some
suggestions from my dissertation I want
to work on or investigate the supposed
relationship between technology desire
and violence not exactly surveillance
State well then uh
my suggestion dating apps
lots of information out there about
ethical quandries that involve the
technology that involve desires
certainly sexual desire but also other
desires like desire to be entertained uh
the desire to like have dominance over
other people and then all sorts of cases
of violence that that have occurred you
know
um that might be a very concrete thing
to to research and examine
uh Reb is there a connection between
schopenhauer and kamu did schopenhauer
influence kamu directly
um I mean kamu read him right but kamu
read a lot of people
and Camus actually
much more optimistic about this this
world that we live in than uh
schopenhauer ever was I will say this
though this is going to be a little bit
of a digression
we often frame schopenhauer as if as if
he's this very pessimistic guy right and
a great schopenhauer scholar who I was
fortunate enough to get to study with
Wolfgang shermacher
um at the European graduate school the
the year that I was uh a visiting
scholar there and my wife was finishing
up her PhD coursework there
um so I was in Schumacher schopenhauer
class and he proposed in in
distinction to the gray schopenhauer
that everybody says although it's so
pessimistic he called it the white
schopenhauer and I think he was modeling
this offer off of Mario's distinction
between the you know I think it's gray
ontology and white theology theology
Blanche of Renee Descartes in his his
books
and um
schermacher was saying here's what I've
you know sort of figured out in my
Decades of studying and thinking about
and applying schopenhauer he's not as
pessimistic as we think the world is
messed up really really messed up human
beings are really really messed up so we
have to figure out what we're going to
do how we're going to make it through
this this world uh we don't need any
like big picture meaning or stuff like
that to try to do it things that we want
everybody else to believe in but we can
figure out what actually will make us uh
any even use the word happy there you
know
um and I think there's there's like a
similarity there to how kamu treats
dealing with this uh absurdity between
us and and the world as well so
all right
um
Rexel Quiz Pack how does one marry to
Mystic metaphysics with hussarel's
phenomenology I mean why in the hell
would you want to do that
um
but if you did want to do that I mean
maybe you could read Edith Stein who
kind of did that
right she actually by the way was the uh
honored guest at the very first day of
the Societe Thomas uh day of studies
she was the person who was presenting
their
um
and it was
1932 I want to say
um so you know maybe look at that or um
I mean why who's certainly in
phenomenology why not cooler stuff like
shalerian phenomenology like the Lublin
school did or
um you know heideggerian you know or
pick whoever else you want
um
so yeah Raya hard to keep doing
something for a long time if you don't
like it but this person may end up
liking it a very good point yeah
although people do things that they
don't like for years and years and years
my uncle Hubert who uh you may have seen
my video talking about him
uh massive influence not just on my life
my whole family's life
um
he uh
you know he had a um a grocery store for
quite a while and it went bust because
um you know he he uh extended credit to
people who he knew couldn't pay just so
that he could keep the food economy
going in his part of Chicago and then he
had to go to work as a welder which he
was very good at incredibly talented I
mean he was there were a lot of things
that Uncle Hubert was very very good at
um but he hated it he was not into it at
all and he worked that job for 30 years
before he could retire from it and then
leave it behind all together
um people do that you know I I've known
plenty of people who work jobs that
they're not into because it puts food on
the table and there's nothing wrong with
that I think you know
um Tobias Solberg how much of early
Heidegger do you need to read and
understand in order to get the late
Heidegger exactly 150 Pages you know and
they have to be exactly the right pages
I mean there aren't any real answers to
these sorts of questions you can you can
jump into the late Heidegger without
having read the early Heidegger and
you're not going to understand uh
everything that you're reading anyway so
um especially the first time that you're
reading it you're going to have to keep
going back over it and you know go back
and forth and stuff like that I mean I
it depends too which which early
Heidegger should you read you know some
of the early essays like what is
metaphysics or the whole of being in
time or maybe certain lectures on things
it kind of depends on what work you're
going to you know and you got to realize
too that Heidegger thought these things
through and changed his mind about stuff
uh down the line you know as well
[Music]
what what philosopher is best in times
like today in your opinion there is no
best
um if I thought there was a best you
would see me working just on that
philosopher I suppose right that would
be the practically prudent thing to do
but I don't think that there is a best I
think that we uh think about the
situations that we're in and then we
look for the resources that might help
us and it's a constantly cobbled
together process that we have to revise
at different points so there isn't there
isn't a good answer to that one
uh uh lap says Luca's earlier question
got me thinking about periods in my life
when my confidence and philosophy waned
other times certain Works strike me as
profoundly true I just have a hard time
saying why I think that's that's a
common experience yeah
um there's a lot of people have liked
the idea that like philosophers they
live this completely rational life and
they understand what they're doing all
the time and you know when they decide
to read this person they have great you
know reasons they've ruled out all these
others and it just doesn't work that way
at all you know so much of what we do is
a matter of contingency and what the
Ancients called Fortune you know or
chance and you know we we get things
that were
into for a while and then you know we
we're not so interested in them I mean I
went through a whole bunch of phases you
you could see videos about those things
and I you know I threw myself into them
when I wasn't partying and you know
having uh relationships and stuff like
that or worrying about mundane matters
or working hours or things like that
um but you know that that's that's a
good point they're
you're not going to be like as we say
firing on all cylinders all of the time
um there might be periods of you know a
year where you're just not that enthused
about stuff and life will sometimes uh
beat you down that way too you know if
you're going through grief due to
somebody dying or the loss of a job or
relationship you know
um
having to attend to the needs of others
like a child or a parent or you know a
friend those things can you know sap
your energy
um physical
ailments you know
um getting older sometimes uh having
injuries getting covered those sort of
things can take away as well you know
all right
um
Leo says are there any Sci-Fi series you
think are underrated
um
well that's an interesting question
you know we we watched our way through
this American version of a British show
called Utopia
and it was really getting good and then
it got canceled and the reason it got
canceled was that there's the laundry
um
it I think it came out did it come out
in 2020 or 2021 it came out during coven
and the idea of there being a
2020 is a year
um so there's like you know here I'm
going to read the thing a group of young
adults who meet online get a hold of a
Cult Underground graphic novel which not
only pins them as a target of a shadowy
deep State
uh but also burdens them of the
dangerous task of saving the world right
and it's very bloody and there's a lot
of things going on in it
um and it was really quite good it was
it was
um surprising and it just you know it
was the wrong time wrong place bringing
something out about a disease being
spread like that during covid not a
great idea
but how could you have planned that
right uh other underrated series I mean
I'm a huge huge fan of Blake's seven I
watched it when I had covid I watched my
way through the entire
four series of it and holy is it
good and they had zero money to to do it
with you know uh so it's it's a solely
accredited to good writing and good
acting because the special effects are
terrible the scenes are terrible you
know the BBC basically tried to strangle
the show
um
and they didn't know that they were
getting a fourth season either so that's
that's another good Sci-Fi show
um
yeah what others I don't know I'd have
to think about that more
um hanzia says if you read the god
series by Mike hockney no I haven't read
it I've never even heard of it is it is
it like a uh speculative fiction thing
maybe or I don't know
um Arcturus is Heidegger's intro to
metaphysics a good place to start with
him
how does it relate to his other work
um I actually start people with a
different thing
um
what is metaphysics and I choose that
one which I put videos out on as my
introduction to Heidegger for people
because Heidegger is taking a lot of the
the big themes of his work
um
you know like the history of metaphysics
and anxiety and the nothing and all
these things and he's he's bringing them
together in a way that connects them up
and
um you know it's challenging but it's
not too challenging and as he points out
at the very beginning every metaphysical
problem is connected with other ones
which I think is a great thing for
students to learn because they often
like you know want to split things into
well this is this and this is this and
this is this right and none of that
there's no connections between these and
Heidegger's saying no no it's all it's
all connected up not in simple ways but
so that that's what I uh start them off
on uh on Olivia what are your thoughts
on Rory if you're talking about Amelie
rorty I think her work is awesome she's
made massive contributions to the
history of philosophy I have a lot of
her edited volumes like you know essays
on Aristotle's uh Nick
X and essays on Aristotle's uh rhetoric
and essays on Descartes
meditations she's she's awesome if
you're talking about Richard rorty
um yeah he's okay you know I think he
was one of those people who was a big
deal for a while and nobody will be
talking about him 100 years from now
I've always found his his takes on on
things rather superficial and he's he's
pretty dismissive of a lot of you know
um
traditions of philosophy that I think
are important I think in part because he
hasn't spent the time to really
adequately read them occasionally makes
interesting contributions
um
but you know you gotta you gotta work to
to find them I would say
uh Lord Tennyson's pipe is Plato's Greek
considered good or beautiful writing
definitely yeah is that ironic
considering his critique of poetry and
speeches and some of his dialogues
ironic in the Contemporary sense where
you say yeah there's a dissonance here
sure
um you know we know that Plato was
himself a poet right
and then he he leaves that behind but
you know like Nietzsche said he produced
a new genre of literature himself right
uh Nietzsche has a pessimistic or
pejorative view on this it's this taking
the planks of the Shipwreck of all the
previous forms and cobbling them
together but you know some people
consider the Symposium to be one of the
finest works of Western literature
um so that's that's pretty High Praise
right so is there I think it's better to
say there's a tension between his
condemnation of the poets end of poetry
end of rhetoric and the incredible skill
that he himself shows with both of those
including mimesis of poets and writers
in his dialogues not least in the
Symposium right where he imitates the
comedic poet
um
Aristophanes who's a character in it and
he imitates gorgeous as rhetoric putting
that into the mouth of uh agathon so
yeah
all right uh Google user have you seen
HBO succession only when my wife is
watching it and I find it totally
uninteresting myself
um I'm not usually into shows like that
you know contemporary business people
and their family Dynamics I just there's
there's other stuff I'd rather watch
Mark uh if we conceive of a child not
only as a biological status but a
familial role what are some
characteristics you would Define a good
child notably in adulthood and
conversely a bad child oh that's that's
a great question
so
you know if we if we think about role
ethics which you see like for example
very heavily in Epictetus right or in
Cicero but also I would say to some
degree in Aristotle and Plato and and
their Traditions as well and then later
on carrying forward into early Christian
thought and medieval Christian thought
um very often the Ancients and medievals
thought of like
the relation between child to parent as
not
not like other relationships it's quasi
divine right because they are the the
the the not creators but the generators
of your being and so you owe something
to them right
um
now what would that comprise
um it's interesting if we think about
this so
it's going to change as time goes on
right so early on you should you know
try to learn from your parents and work
within the household cooperate do your
part
um whatever resources they're giving you
try to use those prudently will we do
that of course not we'll kind of you
know screw up because we're kids and
actually the parents are usually
screwing up half the time too
um
when you become a parent you realize how
hard it is to be a good parent
so there's that going on right
and then you know as our parents age
particularly in a time when the Aged are
becoming very very vulnerable to
exploitation by others within you know
um late capitalism uh where protections
are taken away from them in order to
enrich other people
we you know we have to be like Advocates
and Defenders of our parents even if
they're hard to get along with you know
um and and you know be prudent in that
not like always it's it's not an excuse
to like oh you were controlling with me
so I'm going to be controlling with you
it's more it's more about like helping
to you know reason with them and to make
it to the point too where like if they
start suffering dementia you know we
have to start making decisions for them
and they don't like that usually they're
they're usually kind of upset by that
right
so um I would say that's that's part of
it and then you know another aspect
that's that's very important
um
figuring out how to get through all the
the crap that we went through together
and imposed upon each other
you know
um
so you know we those of us who had
parents for a long time
um
our parents weren't perfect and they
screwed some things up and learning how
to
whether we want to forgive or not
forgive you know what we're going to
hold them accountable for and what what
what they're going to hold us
accountable for
we have to work our way through that you
know
if we want to have a strong relationship
with them so I think that's that's
important too
uh edamar says as my question about
Freud and Nietzsche been sent I haven't
seen anything
um you know maybe if if your question
isn't showing up maybe you put some
words in there that are like uh
getting flagged or something
vegan sports bar do you think it's
possible to change habits after 30 not
only is it possible I see it all the
time
and I've done it myself so yeah of
course uh 30 isn't a magical number and
you can even not only learn habits you
can all or change habits you can like
learn languages or you know learn
mathematics all the things that people
are like oh no no you can't do that
unless you're young they're full of crap
it's a little bit more difficult to
learn languages but you can do it people
do it all the time
um
Riser I want to really get into
Kierkegaard are there any must-read
academic pieces on him
I mean nothing comes to mind for me but
I don't spend much time reading academic
pieces on thickers I spend time reading
the thinkers so
I don't know
um sure there's probably some great ones
out there but I don't I don't read a lot
of secondary lit on Heidegger can't
bought any tips on reading philosophy
got a whole video out on that you know I
find it extremely hard to read
um well keep at it and the more that you
do it the less extremely hard it's going
to be I mean if you're finding it
extremely hard right now that's that's
either a sign that you're you're
approaching it in ways that are
counterproductive uh which you might
want to take a look at you might want to
read that watch that video again or any
of the other many things out there on
how to read philosophy or you're
exaggerating and you want to drop any
sort of exaggeration and be very honest
with yourself if something is difficult
that doesn't mean that it's extremely
difficult you know
um I I have students that I you know
I've had students for more than 20 years
now many of whom don't think of
themselves as particularly smart but
they're able to work their way through
Plato and Aristotle on the stoics and
all sorts of thinkers in my my classes
so you know
I think most people can do
a decent job reading philosophy
all right uh Mark I feel Plato's skill
for satire in his dialogues is often
underrated his humor can often be quite
sophisticated that's very true and this
is why re-reading is very important
right sometimes you're not going to
catch everything the first time through
or the second time or the tenth time
um Plato is a complicated thinker you
know this is where actually reading
secondary lit might get in your way if
you read somebody and they're like
here's the hermeneutic to understanding
everything in Plato you know in these
five easy steps
don't buy into that stuff because it's
not that simple you know
um all right uh Nolan what is a good
thing to say to people who dismiss
things for their evil creators like
people who say we shouldn't read Nazi
philosophers or really listen to really
evil music
I mean why are you wanting to spend your
time reading Nazi philosophers and
listening to really evil music you might
want to give that a think a bit and you
know the need to to like you know ask a
question about that is is itself a
little bit interesting
um what do you need what's a good thing
to say to people who dismiss things
through their evil creators you could
say well you know like a million other
people have said
uh the originator of an idea or the
originator of an artwork is not the same
thing as the idea or the artwork itself
um
I mean if you're if you're interested in
doing historical research and
understanding
um why the Nazis were doing what they're
doing that's that's a reason to read
mind comp when you do read mind comp
um you'll be like holy was a lot of
this stuff deranged you know it's hard
to believe that people actually took
this seriously but they did you
know but then look at all the other crap
that was being published at that time
and look at the the nonsense crazy
that people who are super into racism
published today as well you know
um so I think it's probably enough on on
that
um Lord Tennyson's pipe I recommend Mary
renault's the charioteer it's about two
former soldiers in 1940s England who
tried to form a relationship according
to the ideas of Plato's faders that
sounds like an interesting idea
um there was also a short story out
there
and I don't remember who it was by
but it was like a Sci-Fi thing in the
future and they were also drawing on the
Symposium
um
um and they were talking about faders's
speech about the Army of Lovers you know
which is based on the uh uh
uh thieben unit right and
the idea was that they would they would
produce something like this
it was some sci-fi author and they they
explicitly referenced the Symposium uh
fatal fatal speech right I think yeah
um
all right uh hanzla the god series is 32
books about the Pythagorean the
Illuminati society and their school of
thought well you lost me at 32 books you
know I got so much stuff to read I do
not think I'm going to invest myself in
somebody else's series that I haven't
already committed to that has 32 books
so uh people who enjoy that
uh they can they can uh go out of that
black prairie what is the song you use
for the intros in your Spotify episodes
well I don't I don't have Spotify
episodes you mean my SoundCloud uh
Sadler's lectures podcast episode which
you're probably listening to on Spotify
which is by the way not the place you
want to get it because
um Spotify Apple music they only they
only give you the last 500 episodes so
there's actually like over 800 episodes
out at this point in time I don't know
offhand I'd have to go and like look it
up
somebody asked me about that recently
and then they said that they use Shazam
to figure it out I would do that you
know
um it's from moose open uh where I get
all of my classical music but I don't
remember I mean I started the podcast
back in
2017 I think and it's just a sound file
now so
all right
um
alareza what characteristics in humanity
and human beings will still be Exquisite
resembling A Touch of Magic when through
science we can figure out causes and
reasons of everything related to us well
that's a big win isn't it that should be
an if right off the bat and that one uh
requires some thinking about will we
ever figure out the causes and reasons
of everything related to us prospects
are not good for that
um not not now not in the distant future
that is a very interesting like science
fiction or speculative fiction idea uh
and I would I would actually look at you
know Works in which that has been
addressed like uh Dan Simmons Hyperion
cantos uh where the AIS are figuring
everything out to like a 99.9
probability or
um iron banks uh culture series or any
of these things where you've got
something kind of like a a Utopia along
those lines to see what they have to say
that might be helpful for you
uh vegan sports bar uh if according to
Hegel evil is the pernicious and
subjective Eye of the Beholder what
according to Hagel is an ethical action
I mean it's not quite so simple as that
right so your your if is already if
sometimes according to Hegel at some
places in his works because Hegel talks
about evil and good and ethics
all over the place I mean think about
the analysis of ethical action in the
spirit section of the phenomenology
which goes on for paragraph after
paragraph after paragraph I mean here's
what you can say
um
good action is going to be in some way
like thoughtful it's going to be
connected to the totality that you're
within it's not just going to be you
standing apart from it selfishly
pursuing your own ends but sometimes
there's some you know some evil that
gets smuggled in there that's why you
want to look at that dialectic and the
uh uh spirit section particularly the
morality section where there's some
really interesting stuff going on there
I would say
okay all right uh
uh just skipped a little bit
uh
um
[Music]
stradarian
I got another engagement I enjoyed the
session uh yeah good I'm glad I'm glad
that you enjoyed it
um
and black prairie Nolan cross has a
answer for you right there
um vegan sports bar clarifies that
they're talking about evil music like
the Glee soundtrack I wouldn't know I
don't I don't watch glear listen to Glee
all right
um
so I don't know what's going on with
itamar's uh posts but
there's a reference here to the parallel
between the bad conscience and Freud's
super ego do you think there's a
fundamental difference between the two
concepts yeah they're not the same
concept
um bad conscience is within you and it's
you know it's complicated develop
develops over time right in the
genealogy
um it's not the same for everybody the
um uh superego is part of an economy
within the uh the psychological
personality as Freud sets it up right so
there's some overlap but they're not
exactly the same uh concept right and
most of the time you do comparisons it's
not exactly the same concept between two
people
uh showstopper what's the most
depressing nihilistic philosophy book I
can get my hands on I don't know I mean
I'm not reading things to be depressed
or you know just because they're
nihilistic and that's probably going to
be very much uh subjective matter
differing from person to person to
person you know
um so I don't know
um
count bot is it true that in the first
state two stages of Consciousness
Consciousness doesn't realize the object
is its object and the object is more
external to the Consciousness but
through experience which is the negative
moment of reason when it does that the
self sublates from sense certainty which
is corresponding to the logic stage of
reality
I don't know I mean that's that's uh uh
to me that's like at the risk of
becoming word salad there
um I mean you're talking about are you
talking about in hegel's phenomenology
because you didn't even like reference
who who we're talking about here I'm
assuming it's Hegel and that by the
first two stages of Consciousness as you
mean sense certainty which goes on for
paragraphs and paragraphs and paragraphs
and there's stages in it and then
perception or the thing and it's
properties you know before we get to the
uh
um
force in the understanding section
um but I'm not sure why you're talking
about it being the negative moment of
Reason a later section
um that itself sublates from censority
that's that's you know it overcomes
itself rather corresponding to the I
don't know what the hell the logic stage
of reality is supposed to mean what sort
of shorthand that is so so I can't
really answer that question you know and
I'm somebody who reads Eagle a lot so
that might be a sign of something uh
going going off uh Leo says Asimov spoke
about the importance of Science Fiction
and exploring the cultural imagination
do you think any science fiction might
have prepared the public for space
flight or other breakthroughs
uh uh I mean sure
um
I mean space flight
uh what do you mean by preparing the
public like that space flight could
happen or exist I guess that you know
science fiction and science fantasy had
been doing that for a very long time
before we actually had space flight and
you know we're sort of like thinking out
like so talking about the Kim Stanley
Robinson stuff about colonization of
Mars
I like those books because they're
they're like posing some of the real
problems that we're likely to face which
are not just technological problems but
cultural problems
um if we ever do make it to Mars and
start you know transforming it into a
place where human beings could live
um so sure yeah I mean science fiction
does that but it you know speculative
fiction has been around for a very long
time
um in the sense of like you know opening
up possibilities for us human beings
you know think about Thomas Moore's
Utopia or Marge cavendish's uh the
Blazing world or you know Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein which I actually have right
here because I'm teaching these days in
my uh intro to Humanities class
um and then you know further and further
stuff but they don't always do it in
exactly the same way you could say and
some science fiction authors are more
imaginative and some are perhaps less so
all right uh
lapse for Continuum reflecting on the
way I and others have asked questions
that are impossible to answer adequately
on the time constraints modern
philosophy often comes in shorter
packets thoughts on why I don't know
that modern philosophy comes in shorter
packets I mean when you say modern
philosophy do you mean like 20th century
onward because we usually count modern
philosophies beginning you know in the
1600s and people are still writing big
big old books you know
um
all the way up to the present people
haven't stopped doing philosophy in big
old books you know
um so I don't know what this this uh
shorter packets
means or refers to
a Google user I recently saw your video
on your nietzschean phase how did it
change your thoughts on stoicism Plato
and Aristotle didn't because I got into
nature before I got into these others so
you know uh I I started getting into
Nietzsche
um
when I was you know in my teens
um and then you know continued on
um so it didn't it didn't and I never
really bought like Nature's criticism of
Plato anyway or the stoics I knew he was
he was kind of posturing and full of
crap sometimes with that stuff I was
more into the other things that I found
useful in Nietzsche
Henry Martin priest or Maiden uh Dio
actually if I had to pick like you know
people are who's your favorite band and
I've thought about that for a long time
if you asked me when I was in my teens
and 20s it would have been Iron Maiden
and then it changed you know I I got
into other music and for a while it
probably would be New Model Army you
know
um
and then eventually I got back into
metal and if you ask me like well who
are your favorite bands who are the ones
that you listen to the most I don't I
don't have a favorite as such
um but I recognize the greatness and you
know my going back to over and over
again a number of them and you know it
shouldn't be surprising to anybody who
knows classic metal some of them Judas
Priest iron made in massively important
Black Sabbath Deep Purple you know uh
love them both as well
um
you know and then we've got rainbow and
just the first three albums actually you
know the Dio era and then uh you know
Motorhead and tank Raven girls school
you know fit in there I really like rant
um really like uh wasp I do like Kiss
the hottest band in the world but you
know Ronnie James Dio is really an
extraordinary
person
um
I've talked with people who actually
worked with him he could play all the
instruments you know he he knew exactly
what he wanted he's one of the most
intelligent people in the field of heavy
metal and that's putting him up against
people like you know Steve Harris of
Iron Maiden
um who's also you know brilliant band
leader arranger bassist you know all
this this sort of stuff so it you know
there's like a very rich complex
ecosystem it's interesting because Iron
Maiden and Judas Priest actually did
tour together once early on uh back when
Paul diano was in the band and I guess
he was a real prick to them you know
nobody could really stand his his BS and
it was often framed like that in like
Hit Parade or in Circus you know Judas
Priest Iron Maiden which is the best
because they reviewed as like being at
the top of the the Continuum but you
could say well wait a second what about
Motorhead you know uh what about these
these newer thrash bands like Metallica
and Megadeth you know where do they fit
in and of course we've got the Scorpions
that accept and you know uh girl school
and a few other bands as well to talk
about
all right
um
oh thanks the fantasy Network says you
rock now speaking of Dio that of course
is uh we rock one of one of the the
first songs uh on one of the first
albums uh if you haven't heard it you
should
definitely listen to it
um
Tobias which group of followers is the
most annoying hegelians platonists
marxists
um I mean
plateness aren't usually that annoying
um
that's a good question okay so so
Marxist and higalians uh very often
include people who have read glosses
more than actual texts and they've got
like a shtick right and they they tend
to be very team oriented you know I'm on
team Hagel team team marks and I would
say that um you know it's not platonists
it's more like people who describe
themselves as aristotelians or Thomas
who haven't actually read enough
Aristotle or Thomas or who who are
certainly like not you know getting the
spirit of their dialectical approaches
to things they can be incredibly
annoying you know and you tend to find
it used to be that you'd only find them
in Catholic circles and now you find
them in a lot of protestant circles as
well and they'll tell you you know what
exactly Aristotle's Doctrine is and what
he means by this and that why it's so
Superior to Modern stuff and you'll be
like man you're full of that's not
what Aristotle said at all here's here's
the text here's what he's actually
saying I think a lot of people who build
themselves as stoics today especially if
they don't read the stoic text or they
read them very selectively uh basically
to try to do self-help stuff or to try
to do a grift they're pretty annoying
um Nick land's followers used to be or
you know Fanboys really more than
anything used to be pretty annoying but
I think that a lot of them have since
you know left the building and abandoned
him for other stuff is he took a hard
right turn
um
people who want to talk about g-jack
constantly are kind of annoying
um
but you know I I don't I don't spend a
lot of time letting myself get annoyed
frankly I just kind of
move on from them when and if somebody's
kind of a jerk I just block them and
then I don't have to see their their
stuff you know
uh John garrel thoughts on the
distinction between continental and
analytic philosophy it's kind of silly
and parochial
um I've got you know a talk out there
that I I gave years ago invited at
Virginia Commonwealth I think it was on
the analytic Continental Divide saying
you know yeah there is a thing called
analytic philosophy there's things
called Continental philosophy and then
there's philosophy as a way of life
history of philosophy comparative
philosophy
um you know Traditions like Tome is um
that didn't go away you know feminist
philosophy which doesn't fit neatly into
either classical American philosophy you
know non-western uh traditions in
philosophy and to think that that the
world of philosophy split into analytic
and Continental when there's like this
entire other range around it is really
quite silly
um it's sort of like saying you know in
football yeah there's only two teams
there's the Chicago Bears and the San
Francisco 49ers and all the rest of them
are just minor league no there's there's
all sorts of teams right and we we every
once in a while add a new one to the to
the mix so you know
I I think
the the analytic Continental Divide
thing that was kind of an old topic back
when I was in grad school and I think
that you know it's not particularly
relevant or important for philosophy now
uh vegan sports bar are there any works
that you think translations can't really
do justice
um
I've read some of the Greeks and Germans
in English and I always wonder what I'm
missing out on
well I mean the good news is I can't
think of any text in Greek or German
that can't be translated
I don't know about languages that I
don't know like classical Chinese or
Arabic what's being missed or left out
but I can say that you know there's
there's
you're always going to miss something
right the question is and so the the
Criterion shouldn't be is every single
Nuance of meaning conveyed that's not
going to be the case you know
um but uh
no I'm pretty optimistic about
translation because I'm a translator you
know I've done a lot of that that sort
of work oh I didn't realize how late
it's getting uh I am gonna have to wrap
this up because I have another thing to
do at the top of the hour let's see what
else I can quickly trans or render an
answer for from people who
um haven't had the chance to ask
anything before
um
pipeline 73 on the Continental analytic
divide doesn't Continental philosophy
generally preserve more of what Pierre
doe and others have tried to say was the
origins of philosophy a way of life it
does not
um there's plenty of Continental
philosophy that is just as abstract and
removed from life as analytic philosophy
is we shouldn't romanticize philosophy
as a way of life and
um Ado is actually wrong as many people
have pointed out in in making these
sweeping claims about that's what
philosophy was all doing some of his
critics have attacked him particularly
on what the pre-socratics were doing on
what the platonist and Aristotelian
School were doing so we we want to avoid
like that sort of big picture sloppy
thinking about that Gilgamesh would you
agree with Hegel that there was no
history of philosophy in places uh like
America before colonization Africa and
even with China he doesn't think
Confucius is a philosopher so Hegel
doesn't say there was no history of
philosophy says there is no history in
Africa much bigger claim right that's in
his philosophy of of history and I think
hegel's full of on that I mean he
it was a foolish thing to say there was
already enough information available to
him to not you know give in to that sort
of silly racism
um but he did and so this is you know a
weak point in his Works doesn't mean we
have to throw him away but he certainly
should have known better
um so yeah let's see if there's any
other ones
Roger says do you know any philosopher
from the 20th or 21st century that try
to create a big system like Hegel yeah
there's plenty of them out there I mean
we used to actually get these books by
this self-published guy at philosophy
departments who like worked out a whole
system and I forget his name was Paul
something or other and he'd send all
these books for for free there's there's
lots of people trying to develop uh
systematic approaches to things
um I doubt that will ever end you know
there's there's always going to be
people doing that
um
see here
uh
uh here's here's a good one to go out in
so from fantasy Network what is the most
metal speculative fiction series you've
read and why is it the second apocalypse
so we're talking about our Scott backers
seven book at this point series uh
really really great imaginative stuff I
would say Dan Simmons Hyperion cantos
arguably approach that you know
um what are there any other ones that
I've read recently
that you know really develop the worlds
and and are brutal you know I think we
want to think of like death metal and
brutality and stuff like that
um I mean it's it's tough to top our
scat backer in that
um so I know he might be he might be the
one if you haven't read his stuff you
definitely want to check it out and I've
got some videos about his his work as
well all right so I gotta I gotta head
out
um we're actually way past the time so
uh it's easy to lose track of time when
when we're doing this sort of activity
thanks to all of you for your questions
and uh we'll do this every month we got
some other good events coming up later
on this month and I will see all of you
somewhere down the line somewhere else
in the ether
foreign